dans la nuit du 5 au 6 avril dernier
débute un long combat contre les
éléments
pendant près de vingt jours viticulteurs
et arboriculteurs déploie les grands
moyens pour protéger leurs cultures
une lutte incessante et incertaine deux
mois plus tard le résultat de cette
bataille contre le gel est mitigé les
dispositifs ont limité la casse mais
n'ont pas fait de miracle là on voit des
des baguettes où il ya pratiquement rien
et bonjour sont morts et qui a plus rien
donc là là ce qui va ressortir ça va ça
va être pas grand chose
par contre c'est vrai que quand on voit
des des baguettes comme ça ou des
baguettes comme ça il ya déjà beaucoup
plus sur la sur la baguette
là on aura peut-être 50% de la rente du
rendement dans ce vignoble de
l'orléanais les ceps de chardonnay et de
pinot côtoient des parcelles de vergers
début avril les producteurs de pommes de
poires et de cerises ont utilisé un
système de protection onéreux mais
efficace l'aspersion l'eau à très basse
température enferme les fleurs dans un
cocon de glace et les préserve des
brûlures du gène
aujourd'hui néanmoins l'état des
cerisiers montre les limites du combat
contre la nature et lanton encore il ya
une chute fait géologique derrière duo
que le gel du mois d'avril
et après il ya eu le temps froid de tout
le mois d'avril et début mai ou qui a
une mauvaise fréquentation
il ya des cerises qui n'ont pas gelé
mais c'est pas pour ça que l on
accrochait une aide d'urgence vient
d'être attribué aux viticulteurs et aux
arboriculteurs 3000 euros par
exploitation
une aide strictement symbolique 3000
euros moi j'ai quand même tous salariés
permanents
plus les moyens qu'on a mis en oeuvre
pour la protection anti gel sous être
3000 euros par exploitant sachant que
j'ai déjà brûlé pour 6 à 7000 euros de
bougies sans compter l'aspersion qui est
un coup le temps passer un coup de pouce
financier supplémentaire les aides des
calamités agricoles tombera en fin
d'année après le bilan définitif des
récoltes dans tous les cas de figure
elle ne compensera pas les pertes de
production